now I want to call back some of the
language we learned yesterday right y
equals x squared is it a function or a
relation favorite trick question
functions are special kinds of relations
aren't they they connect your numbers
but more specifically when you put in
one acts x value you'll get one y value
that ok now we looked at different kinds
of functions what kind of a function is
it is it one to one it's not one to one
is its many to one or more specifically
to 21 because if I give you a nap put a
y-value you can give me two inputs to X
values that would give me that equally
ok so it's not one to one which is why
you can't get an inverse function out of
it like it is what must we do to get an
inverse function I must do some kind of
restriction ok now when you look here
right or rather when you look at the
questions we've been seeing right they
generally provide a restriction to you
they say look I only want this side or
that side when you look good I mean it's
literally a symmetrical right I could
restrict it in some ways anyway I like
okay what am I two options
I can say is less than or equal to 0
which is at that time okay or
alternatively I go the other side okay
there by the way the reason y 0 y 0 and
not one or negative 3 why is that the
important point around which this turns
well number one is the surgery more
importantly though this is a turning
point right it's a turning point so when
I rotate this around or reflect it
rather across the y equals x slide the
tail you point is what breaks the
function right it's what turns it into a
relation okay so anyway that's the point
of interested now it's arbitrary which
one I pick both of them will give me an
equally good inverse function okay so in
some sense is random but in another big
sense it's not random why is it that we
only pick one side or we're defining
this thing the inverse function right we
only select one side and everyone agrees
on which side to pick right why do we
pick one side over the other apart from
everyone's agreed to I guess the
question is why whatever the region hmm
let me ask you this question this
function here this inverse function
where is it used in what cases does it
get used the motion where's the first
time learn about it
probably something like this right
coming back to the very first question
we were looking at the other day right
you learn isten Pythagoras that's like
d7 right so you learn you ought to work
out this side here the square root is
involved okay in this case not such a
big deal prefer change number you're
like oh that's messy right so you get a
cert you getting a rational number okay
but of course it wouldn't make much
sense to say this is the square root of
34 it's a pity wouldn't make much sense
to say that if we had to find the
inverse function using this part of the
domain right because then you're saying
it's a negative number that doesn't make
sense does it okay so why do they choose
this song these values over here why do
they restrict it that way no seriously
why never shoot it that way cuz cuz
that's why we use it right that's where
it's valuable to us that's what it's
practical okay so therefore when we come
to our problem let's just take them one
at a time okay y equals sine X let's
draw this guy it's drawing by the way I
know you're used to drawing him from not
to 2pi not from more than 360 degrees
we're in radiance today but it's going
to be useful to us to actually include
some of the negative domain you'll see
why the second
his side x 12 1 there is no more lon 121
function hood sine x ok there is an
infinite number of solutions for every Y
value you'd like to put in there within
the range ok the range oops ok so
therefore we faced with exactly the same
problem that we have here we must
restrict in some way ok now let's have a
think about this we are trying to come
up with a definition for where this the
inverse function of side where it ought
to exist ok i'll post to you the same
question i posed over here right which
is where do we use this inverse function
where would it be I practical to
restrict it because we have a whole
bunch of choices that way right what
kinds of that is did you definitely want
right well again you come back to these
triangles right if you want an angle
like this okay or like this what kinds
of angles are those number one they're a
cute number two they're positive right
so where are those ankles well thinking
about acute angles that'd be that there
is piled tooth isn't it too ok so we at
least definitely what these angles in
here these are the acute angles ok so we
want that little part of the graph to
part of our restriction ok now if you
say I want this part that severely
limits your options for how you're going
to restrict the rest right for instance
can you get obtuse angles could we
include that in meaningfully in our
restriction of PR and end up with a
function down here and the answer is no
because we're RV obtuse angles they're
here aren't they from PI to 2 pi ok but
the second you include those you've
either got the obtuse angles or the
acute angles because otherwise you break
the one to oneness of the function right
so it's just one of the other rat town's
not big enough for both of them and I
think a cute ones are going to be more
useful to us right are there any other
values we could include well I could go
to the left of the origin condo I can go
all the way down to now how far can I go
what's that value there right negative
PI on to now why do I stop there because
there's a turning point right which is
exactly the same reason why I stopped
over there okay so therefore I now have
this domain okay which is a useful
practical way to restrict the function
the original function from PI on too so
I negative pilot's view to positive
pilots that makes sense okay so if
that's the domain up here okay it's
going to become the range down here
right
exes 2 y's while I figured at domain and
range what was the original wrench the
original ranges from negative 1 to 1
okay so therefore that's going to be my
new domain okay so what's this guy look
like okay I want to reflect him like I
was doing before okay like you saw was
the use way to do it so this time I want
you to draw it again but this time
number one drawing bigger number two
let's just do the restricted pie okay
number three I want you to take care
even this graph is not very good for
this we're going to reflect across what
line y equals x right now to make this
look reasonable I want y equals x to
look like y equals x right so I'm going
to need to get this 45 degrees happening
right the thing is you know a lot about
how X and sine X relate to each other
particularly there at the origin where
they form the angle okay what's the
special relationship between X and sine
X of the origin think back to when we
were doing differentiation and we think
about the duties of the trig functions
they're tangent to each other they're
all right so therefore you're going to
need your sine X to go off at 45 degrees
which we don't tend to draw a life I
certainly haven't drawn it like that
here okay so when you're drawing your
new one which is bigger and is
restricted from negative pi/2 to pi/2
just watch for that angle okay let's
draw it now and see what the reflection
looks like
by the way as you're drawing it to help
you with the scale right because I try
to get this 45 degrees happening that
means that the X scale and the Y scale
are the same does that make sense
because if i if i squish or a vice you
know stretch that's what makes it about
45 degrees okay so therefore you
actually know that that is you're
interested in for example if this is one
right what's the domain going to be we
said was going to go to pilot ooh what's
positive you know what planet two is
it's a number it's like 1.5 seven or
something like that right so that should
be fifty percent longer than this one go
further across
so at the very least you need to have
all of those markings there you will not
be able to draw this accurately without
opens okay so i'd recommend you start
off by drawing your original function
okay just try sine X which is going to
be locked in here and there okay you're
going to end over here and here okay now
to make sure you draw this accurately
you get the shape shape is everything
shape is critical okay what's happening
at the endpoints wine i select them as
endpoints remember they're turning
points aren't there so therefore here's
the way I draw them in right I place my
endpoints and then I say well I've got
ever heard of zero there no no right
often when I'm drawing if I draw from in
here and I'm drawing now I often don't
end and get it right you know I ended a
funny angle okay so by putting a
horizontal idea that's my visual cue to
actually get there and make my shape
accurate safety happening over here that
should be horizontal okay there's one
more marker I have which said that it's
going to be 45 degrees at the origin
right so I'm going to draw a 45-degree
angle in there like so okay and now i
can connect the dots
there you go is my sign X all that work
just that one line okay but at least the
shape is accurate the curvature is
accurate okay
oh that's bad let's try that again
that green line green died line that's
going to be the line across which I
reflect this shape now if you have
another color and i think i've run out
it will be really useful to you so try
and make them easy to distinguish how
should i do it i'm not doing green now
remember everything is swapped X's and
Y's or swapped okay i have um turning
points right and horizontal tangents
these endpoints force 8x right let me
say that again I have turning points and
horizontal tangents at these inputs for
sine X so therefore for sine inverse
what should you expect if X's and Y's
are all swapped instead of horizontal
tangents right you're going to expect
vertical tangents right so just like I
did before I'm going to say if this is
my end point over here right it must
absolutely get to a vertical line if I
don't it doesn't represent what
scientific sine inverse looks like okay
and I'll do the same thing down here
okay I've already got this 45 degree
angle in the middle that I need to get
to okay so I'm going to try my best to
draw it accurately and match all the
features that I'm expecting
so close
now can we note a couple of things
because of this domain restriction in
business right y cosine inverse of X is
not the same thing as x equals sign line
which is just swapping the X's and Y's
can you see that what would it look like
if it if I did draw x equals sign why
what would the difference be remember
what the difference is I am I restricted
here right our street to hear which
ended up with restricted here if I made
no restriction right it just said just
swap it right then I'm gonna get this
thing's going to keep going right it's
going to keep going up and down just
like regular sine X keeps on going left
and right okay so it'll stretch on
forever that way its range would be all
real values just like the domain of side
access all about okay so please do not
mix them up right it's not simply x
equal sign way another way you can think
about it is you know it's very close to
this you put in a value like say one
okay and what it gives you back is an
angle like pie on to ok so fine if I say
that right sine inverse of 1 is equal to
PI onto that's what i read off the
ground ok i can always interpret that as
saying okay Sonia verse of one is the
angle such that if I take sign of that
it gives me one hmm can I say that again
that's confusing signing of a sub 1 is
an angle right it's the angle such that
if i take side of it i'll get one ok so
that's the way in verses relate to each
other just like e to the X and log X
right